I have her friend lives in Montreal,
his name is James.
Simon is a great painter and he's taught
me a lot of things,
helped.
He's helped me design my house and
beautify it and I bought some paintings
from him a couple of years ago and he
did this series of paintings where he
went around North America and stood in
different places and then he painted the
view from here down and so it's his feet
planted in different places on roads in
the desert on the ocean.
I have one actually hanging over my
toilet,
which is him standing at a urinal.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
he was trying to make a point and the
point was that wherever you are,
it's worth paying attention and that's
because you know,
so all these places that he visited,
he looked exactly where he was standing
by the side of the road and the desert
sort of mundane in some sense,
but then maybe he put 40 hours into that
painting.
You know,
when it's very,
very realistic painting with really good
light.
And what he's telling you as a painter
is everything is worth paying attention
to.
An infinite amount,
but you don't have enough time and so
the artists does that for you,
right?
The artist looks and looks and looks and
locks and locks and then gives you that
vision and so then you can look at the
painting and it reminds you that,
right where you are is there's every.
Everything that there is is right where
you are and that's a hard thing to
realize,
but it's actually true.